Prosecutors in the rust
fatal shooting case
plan to dismiss charges against the actor
Alec Baldwin.
In the case of that fatal
shooting on the set.
The movie set of Russ Baldwin
and a weapons
supervisor were charged
with involuntary manslaughter.
You may remember
in the shooting death
of the cinematographer
Helen Hutchinson
and entertainment reporter
Chloe Mills is breaking this story.
This is a significant move
by prosecutors.
As I understand it,
there is still charges
standing against the codefendant
in this case.
Can you tell us
where this stands and is it over for good
Well, listen, so what we are hearing
is that prosecutors in New Mexico
are going to be filing
those documents
today or tomorrow
ahead of a scheduled status hearing.
And this is ahead
of what was supposed to be
a criminal trial
with Alec Baldwin
and who you said
the codefendant, Kenneth
Gutierrez, Reade,
who was the armorer on Rush.
I want to read you a statement
from Alec Baldwin's
attorneys, Luke Nikas and Alex Spiro.
They tell CNN
we are pleased with the decision
to dismiss the case against Alec Baldwin
and encourage a proper investigation
into the facts
and circumstances
of this tragic accident.
So we know that the next hearing
was expected to take place on May 3rd
a preliminary hearing ahead of the trial.
Unclear
if that is still
going to be taking place,
but this is a big moment
for Alec Baldwin.
Alec Baldwin sat down with me
last summer,
and he adamantly denied
ever pulling the trigger.
He said that it was anybody's
fault but his
but know
he cried in that interview
with me, telling me
that there's not a day
that goes by that
he doesn't think about what happened,
what happened to Helena Hutchins.
And the irony of all of this news today
is that today
the movie Rust resumed filming
after more than a year
since Helena Hutchins died
there at Yellowstone
in Montana,
filming for about 20 to 25 days.
And so this is all happening
on the same day
to go back and film
that movie as part of a settlement
between Alec Baldwin,
the production of Rust
and the family of Helena
Hutchins, the widower Matthew Hutchins.
And that was just recently sealed
by a judge. But this is a massive moment.
We haven't heard anything
from Alec Baldwin.
We've reached out to the prosecutors,
the D.A.
in New Mexico for further comment.
And I just want to point out
that this comes about a month
after the special special
prosecutor, Andrea Reid, stepped down.
And it comes after the D.A.
recused herself from from this case.
Chloe Melas, thanks so much.
And please stand by.
Quite a development in this story
we've been covering for some time.
We're also joined
now by attorney
and legal affairs commentator
Areva Martin.
Areva,
as we understand it, this is a dismissal.
This is a major development.
The case,
no matter how it
no matter how you slice it,
but dismissed without prejudice
and charges,
still stand against a codefendant here.
Does that allow the investigation
and the case
perhaps to be resurrected against Baldwin
or is he free and clear?
In theory, it does, Jim.
But I cannot imagine
that any district attorney
would resurrect
those charges
given this bombshell news today
in terms of dropping the charges,
the involuntary manslaughter charge
against Alec Baldwin.
We know that the gun enhancement charges
that were filed against him
have been downgraded just this February.
So I think for all practical purposes,
Alec Baldwin is out
of any criminal jeopardy
as it relates to this incident.
Remarkable move now.
Now, you followed
this case for some time.
What do you think the key was here?
What is your read as to why prosecutors
abandon this case?
I think
the thing
that we
can point to until we hear
directly from these prosecutors
is the recusal of the prosecutor involved
in this case.
I have to imagine that the new person,
they came
on, maybe looked at this evidence
and said
there is not enough evidence here
where we can get
a verdict, you know, a conviction,
you know, at trial
we can't convince jurors
beyond reasonable doubt,
which is the standard
in a criminal trial,
that Alec Baldwin is guilty
of involuntary manslaughter.
I can think of
no other reason
that a prosecutor would drop a case.
No question.
We should note that both Baldwin
and the weapons supervisor
did plead not guilty to this.
Now, I wonder that
this would close down the criminal path
so far for Baldwin here.
Are there civil liabilities here
that would still hang over his head
Well, we know, Jim, that
there's already been a settlement
with Lena's family
and that her husband, in fact,
is moving forward
with being one of the co-producers
on the movie
that's filming at this moment.
So I think the
the biggest civil
liability or potential civil liability,
that case has already been resolved.
So I think for all practical purposes,
a good vote is in the clear, so to speak.
He has maintained from the beginning
that he didn't pull the trigger.
He pled not guilty, as you indicated.
So I think this is going
to wrap this chapter for him.